sherry summer is not over yet and we
have a couple of cocktails
to help you cool down let's welcome the
kitchen this is david english from
carson kitchen welcome back buddy good
to see you how are you
awesome so carson kitchen you guys have
one of the best patios downtown
you have the best deviled eggs in las
vegas and you've added some new menu
items what'd you guys add
oh man so right now we have a short rib
steak that we sous-vide for about 36
hours in-house
with a little kimchi chimichurri on the
side it's really really good
we do a hawaiian mac salad it's got a
little grilled spam in there so kind of
like a taste of hawaii
some comfort foods you guys going on
yeah so love about carson kitchen
and you guys also have new cocktails
what's the cocktail you have here in
front of us okay so the one right here
is going to be called better than
than ever so it's kind of like a play
into like covet and coming back you know
us in the restaurant industry has been
really really difficult to like kind of
deal with opening and closing and
closing and opening
so this is kind of like an ode to how do
we come back how do we come back
strong how do we be better than ever
that's what i love about the names of
all your cocktails all the meaning
they're all clever names they all have a
meaning behind them
so so what's this one called again
better than ever better than ever
okay what goes into better than ever
okay so you'll see right here a couple
bottles we've got a little bit of bullet
bourbon here
bottle of dry curacao we make a little
bit of basil simple syrup you'll simply
boil that on the stove with half
equal parts water sugar a little bit of
basil and fresh lemon juice and then we
top it off with a little bit of
blueberry preservation get from any
local groceries so this is going to be a
kind of a sweet drink
no it actually balances really really
well because the dry carousel balances
out all that
that flavor and the the sweetness of the
simple syrup and the let's start making
a cocktail let's do it okay show us how
it's done david
the expert here from carson kitchen all
right start with bourbon you're gonna do
about an ounce and a half i've been
doing this for a long time so i've got
the touch i know how much
all your bartenders you work your magic
try that dry cure so
that's gonna be the basil simple syrup
make it look so easy yeah it's
not really that hard well you know
making the right [ __ ] everyone's
laughing at me making a cocktail
making the perfect cocktail is not an
easy thing to do ask my wife i mess them
up every single weekend all right now
you're putting the
jelly in there's what we're doing yes
sir the preserves here's something i
just learned you continue go ahead go
ahead you're gonna shake it up
let me get that david was telling me
that when it comes to shaking
there's a there's a rule with bartenders
when you're shaking a person's drink
you don't like to make eye contact no
you don't make eye contact you can't
look at me
i'll parrot you real quick you give me a
peek-a-boo with what you'll do
yeah shake it out really good all right
you pulled the top off here got about 30
seconds here
slide it into this glass and also too i
love the the ball of ice
yeah that really the ice makes the drink
well so does the alcohol i guess there's
your ball of ice
all right oh you know what do i gotta
try this i guess
oh absolutely chucks i gotta try a
cocktail
i got a 15 seconds here okay all right
beautiful
as we get ready to toss the break here
carson's kitchen downtown here we go
yeah it's good that's smooth that's
delicious david thank you so much we
appreciate it
las vegas now right back i'm gonna
finish this good